welcome in welcome welcome to another
edition of market takes i am dionne
bowen reporter at the wall street
journal thank you for tuning in this is
our live stream uh we are back on the
monday routine uh it's monday one
o'clock eastern time
here in well i guess on new york time or
eastern time whatever you like to call
it on july 18th thanks again for being
with us here on market takes this is our
live stream where we break down what's
going on with the markets what's going
on in finance and what's going on with
economic data where is the economy
moving where is it going we're going to
talk inflation we're going to talk
recession but we're going to talk about
how the second quarter earnings as we're
kind of kind of getting into the thick
of the earnings report season we're
going to talk about what the earnings
that we've got tell us we're early on
it's early days but we have learned a
lot because the big banks have already
come out and reported and we're going to
talk about what earnings we're going to
get this week and what those can tell us
about inflation what they can tell us
about a possible recession uh already
already being in one right now here in
the us and you know what the future is
going to tell us a lot of these
companies when they're reporting
earnings people just kind of get focused
in on okay what's this company telling
me what's that company telling me should
i buy the stock but there's a lot of
information that we can unpack from
these earning reports that are going to
tell us a lot about the overall shape of
the economy and especially inflation
look companies drive and are a big part
of driving inflation and what we hear
from these companies is going to tell us
about how they're managing that and what
they're seeing about the forward-looking
outlook and whether they're going to
keep raising prices as they have been so
definitely important that we watch that
and keep an eye on what's going on in
earnings season look we've gotten the
big bank report so far we're going to
talk through that we're going to talk
about what reports to look for this week
which are going to be the most important
and what to look for in those reports
i'm also going to give you my sneaky
important non-earnings report to watch
for this week as well as talk through
just all things markets and the economy
so look before we dive into that let's
take a look at markets i'm on
wsj.com right now we've got the dow
right now kind of hanging on to its
gains for the day it's been kind of
steadily moving down towards that zero
percent flat or potentially negative
territory we've got the s p 500 up about
half a percent the nasdaq holding strong
up about 1.2 percent the nasdaq is
actually close to closing above its
50-day moving average for those of you
stock trader nerds out there that's a
very good sign it could mean that good
things are on the horizon for the nasdaq
it has really outpaced the dow and the s
p uh in recent days as we've kind of
seen the stock market bounce back but
you know it's a technical indicator
nothing uh you know nothing locked in or
for sure about that as we look out over
the rest of the market the 10-year
treasury the u.s 10-year treasury yield
is approaching that 3 percent number
again at about 2.99 right now that's an
important indicator when 10-year
treasury is at 3 percent that's about a
neutral rate it serves as a decent place
or a decent alternative to investors for
stocks so we are getting there again oil
up having a very big day today uh on
increased demand in the falling dollar
we've got oil up about four percent on
u.s uh us crude uswti and brent crude up
more than four percent almost four and a
half percent natural gas of about six
percent you got gold up silver up more
than one percent copper having a huge
day up three and a half percent uh so
all in all right now the markets it's a
pretty bullish day as we look out so
let's take a step back and let's look at
those big bank earnings that we've
gotten over the past few days and even
coming into this morning we heard from
goldman sachs weird from bank of america
just this morning
look the big picture takeaway from the
banks is that the consumer is doing
pretty well now that normally is a good
thing but i'm going to talk to you about
how that could be a bad thing big
picture when we look at the the
recessionary potential environment that
we are in
morgan stanley bank of america jpmorgan
chase wells fargo citigroup all saying
look when we look at our deposit numbers
when we look at our debit card numbers
when we look at what customers are
actually doing in the bank putting money
away they're in pretty good shape we're
all saying credit and debit spending is
strong deposits are solid travel and
entertainment spending continue to rise
and that restaurant spending category
consumers continuing to spend on
restaurants that's a good sign for the
overall economy to stay healthy i want
to read you a quote from jp morgan chief
financial officer jeremy barnum what he
said in with the company's earnings
reports last week i think really sums up
what the banks had to say we've looked
very carefully into the actual data and
results and there is essentially no
evidence of any weakness in the actual
results
the question is about the outlook so the
questions are about the outlook and
again what that means is right now
consumers are holding strong we saw that
strong retail sales number that we got
end of last week one percent increase in
retail sales but remember inflation rose
at 1.3 percent uh last month so again
consumers are buying still spending
money but not spending at the same pace
as inflation is rising um
and one thing that you've got to
remember when we talk about a potential
recession right now and we are in the
third quarter currently the first
quarter was negative we will find out on
july 28th or july 29th excuse me whether
second quarter gdp was negative that
typically means that we're in a
recession but again that's declared by
the national bureau for economic
research they don't review their uh they
don't put out a schedule they don't tell
us when they're meeting they just at
some point get together decide there was
a recession and there wasn't and if
there was we get a press release and
it's it's a recession no other for no
other warning or information other than
that but
whether or not we have a recession will
not be dependent necessarily on whether
you start seeing layoffs and job cuts
nothing what we could really just see is
an environment where prices just keep
going up and consumer wages aren't
keeping up consumers still buy they're
still buying but they're not buying
enough to keep the gdp positive so you
see continued negative gdp prints gross
domestic product and the us growth the
growth of the economy stalls and goes
negative even though people still have
jobs they've still got money in the bank
account
typical recessions that's not what
happens but we might not be in a typical
recession here look um when it comes to
the big banks what they told us you can
ignore those profit statements their
earnings etc it's not really about that
there there is a good reason for
earnings to slow down for the big banks
and that's just that the market was weak
you had negative 19 for the s p 500
year-to-date no one wants to ipo into a
falling market no one wants to catch a
falling knife so to speak so obviously
ipo revenue is down trading revenue is
down all those things the big banks tell
us what's going on with their profits
don't tell us a whole lot about the real
overall economy one thing i do want to
point you out to within those earning
reports i thought it was very
interesting jp morgan the largest u.s
bank suspending its buybacks while the
stock is down 33
citigroup also suspending buybacks now
the banks announced big buybacks in 2021
when the market was strong it stands to
reason that oh market goes down maybe
they don't want to however when prices
are low that's when you want to buy
right buy low sell high well big banks
are notorious for saying hey you know
what our stock price is down we want to
go in buy back some stock that gives
investors a lot of confidence the banks
have confidence well citigroup and jp
morgan two of the biggest are saying we
don't have confidence right now that
things are gonna get better in the near
future we're gonna hold back on buying
back our stock uh it's also gonna be
interesting to see what happens with
dividends banks just announced a couple
of them that they are raising dividends
still trying to pay stockholders to hold
their stock but
very interesting that they're not doing
more buybacks they're pausing buybacks
and actually taking a step back that
tells you there's not a lot of
confidence in the near-term economic
outlook also important to watch of
course as it gets more expensive to
borrow money banks like to borrow money
use that to buy back their own stock
juice the stock price etc etc it's an
old game but they're not doing that
right now so definitely something to
watch out for look as we move into this
week what to watch for earning season
kickoff so far has not been great we've
only got seven percent of companies
reporting but so far only 60 percent
have beaten earnings expectations that's
well below the five-year average of 77
all that means is companies are not
beating earnings at the pace they
normally do not as many companies
beating their earnings expectations
that's not a strong sign uh but the
market seems to be picking up today
in spite of not so great earnings so
we'll see how that goes this week we get
reports from johnson and johnson and
netflix on tuesday tesla united airlines
verizon and a t as well as excuse me i
skipped a couple lines on my on my cheat
sheet here tesla and united airlines on
wednesday 18t capital one and dominoes
on thursday and we've got verizon and
american express on friday uh so that's
what we've got all this week look i
think if you're trying to find out and
suss out what's going on with the
economy there's a few reports that are a
little bit more important than others to
watch i want to point a few of those out
to you right now
the first few united airlines verizon
18t and dominoes
united airlines last week we got some
bad news from delta they still managed
to to make a profit during the quarter
but fell well short of expectation so
the big question with united is how much
of those fuel costs hurting as i just
talked about in our market look back
oil costs are back over 100 a barrel
they were clearly well over that during
much the second quarter how are the
airlines handling that are they still
able to make a profit if you've tried to
book a trip this summer you know how
expensive airline fares have been how
how successful the airline's been about
raising those prices and still being
able to turn a profit with those higher
fuel costs and what's their guidance
going forward into the fall and into the
winter of this year when they're not
going to see as much of that summer
demand as they have been verizon and att
could show some pullback from consumers
uh they both have increased their prices
recently how are they dealing with those
price hikes or consumers just paying up
and saying all right well my my cell
phone bill went up i'll pay the extra
money or are people switching to lower
cost carriers they switching to lower
priced plans that's what we're going to
find out from those two also you've got
a t moving away from warner media that
divestiture this will be the first
quarter we see how they do so they're
going to be a lot more dependent on
consumers paying up directly to them and
what happens to that dividend do they
keep that going these are all key
questions when we hear from verizon and
att this week those wireless character
carriers excuse me
dominoes
expectations for revenue up but earnings
are expected to fall this could be a
bellwether for restaurants in the second
quarter because domino's kind of fits
right in that middle class space now
we've seen continued spending on
restaurants as i talked about earlier in
the live stream we've seen
continued increased spending travel
entertainment restaurants those have
been the strong categories that banks
have pointed out where is that spending
going is it going to places like
dominoes and things like that where it's
a lot of middle class working class
consumers or is it all at the upper end
of the exp of the income train is it
more higher priced restaurants that are
seeing this or is that where people are
pulling back domino's is gonna tell us a
lot about that when they report their
earnings uh this year
or excuse me for this quarter tesla not
one that normally tells you a lot about
the economy because it's the tech stock
it's evs blah blah dan levy at credit
suisse actually said something really
interesting coming into their earnings
report he said the key question for
investors next week will be quote the
magnitude of margin pressure from the
shanghai shutdown due to china's covet
zero policies basically tesla has huge
exposure to china there's a lot of u.s
companies with big exposure to china and
tesla's going to tell us a lot about how
much that shutdown hurt those coveted
shutdowns hurt earlier this year
and that's i think a big test for how
these other companies will do because
you could see a lot of companies with a
lot of international exposure those
multinational companies showing big
declines and how much that is temporary
how much will come back we're going to
learn a lot from tesla look if you read
between the lines on a lot of these
companies we're going to hear a lot on
these earnings calls that i think you
want to be locked into how much your
company is complaining about labor costs
i think that's the number one thing that
investors and people who are interested
in the economy should be paying
attention to companies always when they
miss their earnings expectations or they
miss their growth projections that one
is today they always want to say oh well
it was you know it was this thing or
that thing outside the company it was
never management was never that we
didn't do a great job but the companies
that did well
we know labor costs are rising but labor
costs are rising at a much slower pace
than overall inflation is rising at a
much slower pace about half the pace
that companies inputs are rising
wholesale prices are rising and we know
less than half the pace that companies
grows or sorry net profit margins are
rising net profit margins are expected
to rise by 12.4 percent that's what the
companies take home after paying out
everybody else that number is rising at
much fast at a much faster pace than
labor costs so
if that's the case
why are you as a company having trouble
dealing with your labor costs so how
many companies point to labor costs and
say oh that's the problem it's all over
that
the other thing to watch out for
complaints about is the strong dollar
dollar is about the strongest it's been
in 20 years
right now coming into and in the second
quarter and this quarter it's just
gotten stronger and stronger
particularly against the euro and the
japanese yen so looking out to companies
that do a lot of business in the
european area and in japan if you didn't
do a lot of business there well maybe
your excuse is a little flimsy so look
out for companies complaining about the
strong dollar about fx issues about
currency all those things i think you're
going to tell you that that's probably
just an excuse that you're making for
missing your numbers sneaky important
report to watch this week outside of
earnings taking a step outside of
earnings those initial jobless claims
last week we hit the highest level that
we've been at in a year we are seeing a
continued increase in the number of
initial jobless claims that's number of
people reporting for unemployment
benefits saying they've lost their job
and they now want government benefits
that's been rising pretty consistently
and we saw in june that challenger job
cut report showed that we are seeing a
sustained pickup in layoffs job cuts in
june were 50 higher than they were in
may that's a big jump we are still
historically low so don't get you know
don't go kermit arms on me but we are
still at a historically low pace but we
are seeing an increase in layoffs
increase in people applying for
unemployment benefits that's definitely
something to keep your eye on so look
we're coming to about the end of market
takes here just going to do our big
takeaways
so far banks have told us that u.s
consumers are doing well but maybe a
little too well because what's going to
prolong the pain here is if prices keep
going up and the only way that prices
keep going up is if people keep paying
them when demand goes away when folks
say you know what those prices are too
high i'm laying back i'm going to stay
at home i'm not going to go out and eat
i'm not going to go travel that's when
prices start to come back down because
the companies say ah man well we got to
do something we can't just keep raising
our prices that's what stops the weight
or the the price spiral of inflation
until that happens inflation could keep
going higher so that's a big thing to
watch for how customers are doing what
they're doing and and why we're also
going to hear about a lot of sectors of
the economy at t verizon dominoes united
airlines i think are keys to watch and
of course tesla don't forget to watch
that initial jobless claims report that
we get on thursday and look the big
question i think is what does the market
take away from all these earnings
reports does it give the market a new
lease on life or no that's the big
question that we have to find out this
week look thank you all for tuning in to
market takes i'm still dm rabona as i
was when we started this and we'll be
doing this again next week so please
tune in uh for another edition of market
takes our live stream here for the wall
street journal uh thanks for tuning into
this one and we'll see you next time